hello CEO it's pretty interesting
hearing your perspective on white
privilege I grew up in a town of 500
North Idaho 500 North Idaho that's yeah
that is pretty white and there's a lot
of mining up there they're probably just
mining even looking for anyone that is
not white like you have to dig pretty
deep thank you for calling onward so I
kind of get what you're saying it's kind
of a hard topic to get into because I
think white privilege does exist yeah no
doubt I mean it definitely exists I'm
just saying that then in my life I
didn't get to sign up for it I wish they
had passed around the sign-up sheet
because it was it was not a part of of
my life onward but you know when I was
on a dirt road
you know [ __ ] my dad was a logger
just white trash as [ __ ] you know people
are sharing roadkill or whatever they
shot that hunting season and logger
that's the tree person
none of some people think logger is
somebody this you know you know taking
dumps or whatever all over but logger is
somebody captures trees and our respect
loggers but also at the same time pretty
easy job you know if you were a logger
you're hunting you're hunting trees dude
that's easy you know first of all how
hard is it think about it do it I could
think right now if I really thought
about it
I could tell you where there's probably
about 80 trees I could draw I could even
probably draw them for you and draw you
a sketch of them you know an outline
sheet of information so not that tough
of a job and I respect it homework yeah
I'd like seven people in my class one
girl she was a goddamn Squatch - that
girl was six-foot when she was ten ready
to [ __ ] some [ __ ] man whoa okay you got
a local law you got a real [ __ ] Squatch
in your locality huh let's hear more
about this Wow girl Wow girl she did it
- somebody had
you know keep the neighborhood happy
keep the boys and stabbing each other's
big carry did it they can bear sickness
squishiness good stuff anyway I'm super
stoned but uh thanks for the podcast all
right I appreciate the call man yeah if
you know you had a girl named big Carrie
that was taken you know taking on sex
locally for you know to keep the
neighborhood happy and to keep things at
bay you know and I think I think there
always is somebody like that you know I
think there always is somebody like that
and every in every environment you know
in every time period there's some gal
who's taking one for the team and
sometimes taking the team for one you
know who is you know who's just you know
comes into their sexuality you know at a
at a point maybe others aren't and
really just pops off and makes it happen
for everybody locally and I remember
catching up with a couple of those gals
in different places we had a gal in our
neighborhood it was a swim team she was
big on swim team and she had shoulders
like a dam I mean just like a two-legged
bison brother I mean she just had
shoulders like a dam like a [ __ ] 5'4
French Bulldog man I mean she had
shoulders like a I mean just like a dam
just like somebody in a wheelchair who
lived up a hill you know what I'm saying
she had shoulders like that and she used
to set off a bunch of nut she was always
set in people's nuts off setting off the
men's nuts locally and kind of taken one
for the team at a certain age so I think
we should have a time sometimes when we
respect those types of people you know
because because you know they need you
sometimes you need that you know
sometimes you need to take that edge off
as a group as a neighborhood and maybe
that's what these swingers were doing
you know I'm sitting here judging these
people and I would judge and I judge
them at the time but I mean if to be 50
or 60 and you know and not and be pale
and to say you know what I'm gonna take
these thighs out and down by the you
know down into the Ozarks I'm gonna take
these stars out there and set them you
know and warm them up you know make it
these CAPA
Larry's going and get the blood flow
going you know that's pretty brave
actually it's a lot braver than some of
the stuff that I'm doing so maybe I can
actually learn when I think back on some
of these things instead of you know
maybe this is where I'm learning where
I'm learning not to really you know
judgey swingers you know but that
sometimes an area specific area needs to
just you know needs to let out and that
those gals out there like big carry that
you just mentioned sir and that are and
that there's just there's groups getting
together just to pop off you know just a
blow seed and just you know feel that
vibe pretty in good afternoon and other
times thanks for watching that video you
just saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watches one